Magnus Carlsen erupted in Fury as a
disastrous Mouse slip against
ikaranakamura cost him a nail biter of a
match and secured Hikaru a ticket to the
Grand finals of the chessable Masters in
the losers bracket semifinal Magnus
faced Lavon aronian after managing his
time more efficiently he backed Lavon
into a corner and gained the win in game
two after a brilliant Rook sacrifice
Magnus took the win and moved on to
basic Haro in the losers bracket final
in the first game between Magnus nicaro
many tactics were possible but the game
was eventually drawn in the second game
Hikaru expressed that he literally does
not care and took a quick nap after a
long fight this game was also drawn
leading the match to Armageddon Hikaru
won the bid for the black pieces meaning
that he would Advance with just a draw
the game was intense Hikaru was hunting
for perpetuals but Magnus kept the
pressure up on the board and the clock
the time pressure was starting to affect
both players just when Victory on the
clock seemed near